الآن يقترب عدد القتلى من
الزلزال المدمر الذي وقع يوم الجمعة في المغرب من
3000 شخص بينما تشق المساعدات ببطء
طريقها إلى الناجين
والقرى الجبلية المتضررة بشدة. والآن أصبحت الوكالة الأمريكية
للتنمية الدولية هي الأحدث التي
تعهدت بالمساعدة قائلة إنها
ستقدم مليون دولار أوليًا.  في
الدعم الإنساني للمغرب
وأرسلت فريق تقييم إلى هذا البلد
الآن قبل المغرب مساعدات خارجية محدودة في
أعقاب الزلزال في الوقت الذي يكثف فيه
استجابته للكارثة ينظر ناداش من سي إن إن
إلى ما يواجهه الناجون
الآن في المأوى من الناجين من
الحرارة الشديدة في سبتمبر  من
زلزال المغرب يقضون يومًا آخر في
التأقلم مع المأساة التي حلت
بهذه المنطقة المهتزة، وقد تم إنشاء ملاجئ مجتمعية مؤقتة
لأولئك الذين شردوا بسبب
الزلزال في جميع أنحاء هذه
المنطقة، وقد تم توفير العديد من الخيام التي يمكنك
رؤيتها هنا إما من قبل
المغرب  الحكومة أو من قبل
المنظمات والجمعيات الخيرية المحلية ولكن
الحكومة المغربية طلبت أيضًا
المساعدة من أعضاء
المجتمع الدولي وقد رأينا
هذه الفرق الدولية على الأرض
تقدم الدعم ليس فقط على
جبهة البحث والإنقاذ ولكن أيضًا في
جهود الإغاثة الإنسانية.
الأولويات العاجلة لفريقنا هي
دائمًا إنقاذ الحياة أه بعد
ذلك حيث يمكننا مساعدة
المساعدة الطبية في تحديد الاحتياجات الإنسانية،
لذلك حتى عندما تنتهي مرحلة الإنقاذ هذه، فقد
قدمنا ​​كل المعلومات التي
نستطيعها لمساعدة الإغاثة الإنسانية
التي ستتبعنا
عبر منطقة الزلزال هنا في المغرب،
كان هناك أيضًا تدفق
للدعم من المجتمع المحلي من خلال
التبرعات من الغذاء والمياه
والأدوية، لكن المتطوعين هنا أخبرونا
أنهم ما زالوا بحاجة إلى المزيد من الخيام والدعم الحاسم على المدى
الطويل لجهود إعادة البناء التي
تقول الحكومة.  تعد
إعادة بناء المنازل التي فقدتها في
الكارثة أولوية، لكن بالنسبة للعديد من
العائلات المتضررة، لا يمكن التنبؤ
بالوقت الذي سيستغرقه الأمر قبل أن يكون لديهم
منزل حقيقي للعودة إلى شمال شرق بشير سي إن إن في
المغرب.